There's an interesting contrast of polling
data today.
Donald Trump's approval rating is six points
lower than support for his impeachment.
According to a new poll from Quinnipiac university.
And according to this poll, Trump's approval
is 41% and support for his impeachment and
removal.
This is not support for the inquiry.
This is support for Trump's impeachment and
removal is at 47% support.
This is definitely what you would call polling
underwater and also notable is that the same
poll from September 30th compared to this
poll five days earlier, saw a 30% increase
in the number that want to impeach and remove
Donald Trump.
Five days prior support for impeachment and
removal was 37% five days later support goes
to 47% that's an increase of a 28 ish, somewhere
between 25 and 30% now it's important to understand
the historical context here.
47% already believe that Donald Trump should
be removed from office.
That's not the number of people that are saying
merely start the inquiry and if you contrast
this to Nixon in the 70s impeachment support
for Nixon was I believe in the 20s when the
inquiry started, but very different circumstances.
Nixon didn't have entire media outlets dedicated
to propping him up the way that Donald Trump
has propping him up.
And once again, it is now getting real enough
that the questions of wouldn't Pence be worse,
are starting to come up.
And in many ways he would.
An evangelical Christian supremacist like
Mike Pence would be much worse than Donald
Trump in many ways.
But I don't believe that that is a question
that is going to actually become a anything
more than theory.
Because once again, you know, to either reset
or as a reminder, this impeachment inquiry
is not going to lead to the removal of Trump.
I know every time I say this, a few people
email me, they say, here's how it could, here's
how it might.
Uh, that's great.
I don't think it's going to happen, but hopefully
it will damage Trump's reelection chances
such that he loses in 2020.
We'll keep following the numbers as the process
moves forward.
But I want to hear from you, what do you make
of these impeachment numbers?
What do you make of the historical context
around the impeachment support that there
now is not only for the inquiry but [inaudible]
for the removal of Donald Trump.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I look forward to hearing from you there